o silício que é um nutriente essencial
que o nosso corpo precisa em pequenas
quantidades ele está presente na pele
cabelos unhas ossos e tendões sendo
crucial na produção de colágeno conforme
a gente vai ficando mais velho ou velha
a camada da pele vai ficando mais fina o
que pode levar ao aparecimento de rugas
e outros sinais de envelhecimento a boa
notícia é que o silício tem o poder de
reverter esses efeitos e melhorar a
produção de colágeno e mais ele ajuda a
melhorar a qualidade do cabelo dando
mais volume e fortalecendo os fios Além
disso O silício também atua na
manutenção das juntas do corpo
preservando o espaço articular e
acelerando a cicatrização dos tendões a
deficiência de silício pode causar pedo
de cabelo cabelo quebradiço pele fina
pele irregular ossos fracos fraturas
ósseas deformidades articulares baixa
concentração de colágeno e cartilagem
osteoporose e osteoartrite